pouvez-vous nous dire un peu comment
vous avez commencé à faire de l'art oh nous avons
imaginé une chose que vous ne prenez qu'un
repas par jour
il n'a pas pris ce qui est à nous
merci de vous chevaucher vous devez consulter
votre menu et avant cela James Houston
arrivé à Cape Dorset quel genre d'art les
inuits faisaient juste un regard
viens tu m'as téléphoné pour me dire cuisiner
tout le monde souvent rien ce volume
je me demande ce qu'il faut le vouloir je ne vais
plus marcher près des listicles je regarde l'
Allemagne  alors je suis grand ouvert à
tout le monde notre éco local Christian II
ne prend pas adopté Je
connais ton petit et tu te souviens de la première fois que
tu as rencontré James Houston et sa femme
et qu'as-tu pensé d'eux la première
fois  que vous les avez rencontrés avez-vous l'air bien
vous ne le voulez pas ils ont enlevé l'
eau les dégâts de mon déjeuner parmi les
disparus ils ont pris le long chemin jusqu'à mon
NOLA New York - oh non maman je n'ai pas besoin
de les cuisiner  chaque fois qu'ils étaient chauds sur
la table lui dira Ellen je ne
sais pas  faites-le fonctionner et votre travail
est apparu dans la toute première
collection d'imprimés cape dorset en 1959 et que vous
souvenez-vous de cette époque
saint autre mec d'accord Miguel quelles
vacances que vous un HOH à votre table
et je viens toujours regarder Dave quand ils
arrivent  s'ils l'abandonnent en l'
encourageant, je ne sais pas
quelles sont vos choses préférées à conduire, je
ne sais pas maintenant dr.  leo
aller au-delà d'un chien faire en bas il n'y a
pas je ne peux même pas leur parler
de quoi avez-vous besoin de répéter que votre
médecin ne vous savez pas que vous êtes si célèbre en
particulier pour vos dessins de voyelles oiseaux
huards  Selon vous, qu'est-ce qui
rend votre image si attrayante pour les
collectionneurs et les galeries, non seulement en
Amérique du Nord et au Canada, mais dans le
monde entier,
ça va - non non Jenna voiture chaude - Je
t'aime mais la bagarre -  un jour en
arrière, elle a emmené vers le Dharma
un homme dont mes jambes se sont cassées, elle m'a rencontré après
toutes ces années, je veux dire que vous avez une
carrière extraordinaire de 50 ans derrière vous
avec l'art un moyen pour vous de gagner de l'argent pour
votre famille ou est-ce que l'art vous donne
quelque chose  personnellement et ensuite
spirituellement aussi que pensez-
vous des jeunes
artistes émergents maintenant et de certains des
artistes à mi-carrière certains d'entre eux
font encore ce que beaucoup de gens considèrent
comme l'art inuit traditionnel la faune
le paysage autour de Cape Dorset
certains sont  travailler plus ab  sur les
problèmes sociaux dans la communauté et les
aspects plus modernes de Cape Dorset que
pensez-vous de ces nouvelles images
et de ce nouveau groupe d'artistes émergents
que peut-elle faire aux gens si vous avez
besoin d'un jicama pour choisir ce qu'on vous
donne une photo  au tout petit
défi de la table à relever bien que - nous ne pouvons pas
changer
bhiku rien que je vais faire avec eux
veux parler à nouveau après quand tout le
temps passé Geico crie regarde ils
rient ils se sont trompés avec lui
comment savez-vous que je me déteste  être
là où vous vivez, vous n'êtes pas une façon de
faire ce que vous devez être quand vous avez rencontré Ally,
il a renversé la bouteille d'eau
sur ce qui n'est pas ce que dr.  Fischer pourquoi
nous avons besoin les uns des autres non pas pour lui mais à un
quart d'heure après la vache sacrée dans l'ensemble, c'est
enseignant quand Tommy me gouverne ou non
et comment pensez-vous que les
changements environnementaux pourraient se refléter dans l'art
que les artistes ici produisent mais je vous ai rencontré
une fois par  fille
comment as-tu pu te faire monter Chico d'accord je vais
cuisiner Chico Carl maintenant ne vient-elle pas
pour me cacher tout ça va docteur je
sais ce que dr.  Chico, je suis Meryl Chico, je
ne m'attends pas,
elle espérait que nous ne parlons pas de
rires, bon
maintenant, regarde, tu pourrais faire un tas de
ce que j'ai fait.
-in-cheek fantastiquement maintenant sur comment
pensez-vous que nous avons célébré le 50e
anniversaire de la collection d'imprimés Cape Dorset
l'année dernière que pensez-vous que
la collection d'imprimés Cape Dorset sera
au cours des 50 prochaines années comment pensez-vous que
cela va changer et  comment
pensez-vous que ça va rester le même, ils
ne s'inquiètent pas pour moi
alors je dois marcher sur la pointe des pieds optiquement dans le
sud quand c'est le jour de la
collection d'imprimés cape dorset le jour de
sa sortie vos images sont celles
qui sont achetées  d'abord ce sont ceux qui
sont épuisés en premier et les gens vous appellent comme
la plus grande partie
monsieur de l'art inuit Je suis curieux de savoir comment
vous vous voyez
oh nous faisons un film dont je veux dire vous en
parlez en hiver ils peuvent vous
mettre à jour  eux sur Cordina tu dois avoir un
pour monter la voiture, ils pourraient allumer le
milieu d'un après-midi, nous surveillons que
ce sera culturellement, vous savez, c'était
alors une idée quand un problème
nous en avons assez pour élever vous savez ouais
j'aime quand les gens parlent de toi comme un
produisant de l'art inuit vous considérez-vous
comme quelqu'un qui produit de l'art inuit ou
vous considérez-vous comme un artiste canadien
qui vit et travaille dans le
Nord